that's how Sammy the bull did when but
by the way thank you for hooking me up
we spent two days together brother oh
really saw a bunch of stuff together
took him to dinner did a whole thing
with him was it what you expected 100
and more yeah but the stories dude when
you're sitting there with him and he's
got this he's outside he's smoking hey I
never thought in a million years I'd be
out here in the beach and you know I
just want to thank you you know you
brought me in with your family holy
but it was just like I couldn't I mean
this is the most feared guy ever ever in
that City oh my God I knew you I picked
him up I was nervous dude I picked them
up at the at the airport he's in a
T-shirt and uh and I'm like hey but he's
got a sense of humor about it very funny
we bring him he's he's in the studio of
the fighter in the kid Studio
and uh you know Brennan the sixth I was
just going to say right he's look right
here here oh I shot I'm nervous hell
yeah look at him
I'm talking see how much I'm talking way
too much I don't know what's gonna
happen with his eyes what's in the bag
what's in the bag so so Brendan is there
and then there's Mark Harley who's a
huge big bodybuilder big guy both 240
270. and and Sammy's looking at these
guys and uh he made some hey I don't
yeah how you doing like that and then
there's a pause and they're just
standing there and he goes
now I'm going to arrest you both at the
same time
he's just got he's great do you remember
he said yeah I do that's why I was like
you know yeah you can say that and you
got to say that when you know when
you're when you're with them yeah uh but
maybe he did I don't I don't know if he
did or not but oh the shop is like you
know there's different types of tough
right no but but uh but that's fine but
uh mind you piece yeah and be respectful
that's what I'm trying to tell because
this is me now Sammy I want to apologize
to the account of my friends
yeah we're gonna say but you're about to
say something about him so so one day
Sammy comes to our house this is like a
few months ago he comes to the house
he's going on talking to the kids you
know Dylan's talking to him so that he's
like so what's his name is Sammy the
bull yeah I'm Sammy the bull so Dylan's
like enamored by his name what a great
name Samuel fantastic so he goes to
school the teacher asks him so he says
so how was your day says well Daddy's
friend showed to our house I met a Sammy
the bull oh and he's just like who did
you meet yes this is a Christian School
oh my God so I get a phone call you know
you're sunk enough say that Sammy the
bull was at your house I said what do
you mean he can't say that he can't say
that because he wasn't I said no he was
at the house oh my God which Sammy the
bull I said the same one you're how many
centimeters
can I ask I said yeah he's a he's a he
was he came he's a person that we have
done a lot of collaborations together
with oh I'm so sorry I thought Dylan
just was I said no he's telling the
truth the teacher and then after this
moment the next day the teacher's like
Hey where's your homework and the kid is
like none of your
Dylan finds out yeah
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]